foreign
quick pull
raise your hand if you have a
relationship in your life that's
meaningful to you
okay I assumed but always good to check
our assumptions
I'm saying this because while I'll be
focusing today
on a parent-child relationship please
know that everything I'm talking about
is applicable to any meaningful
relationship
so with that in mind let's jump in
so it's Sunday night
I'm in my kitchen I just finished
cooking dinner for my family and I am on
edge I mean I'm exhausted I haven't been
sleeping well I'm anxious about the
upcoming work week I'm overwhelmed by
all the items on my unfinished to-do
list and then my son walks into the
kitchen
he looks at the table and whines
chicken again
disgusting
and that's it I snap I look at him and I
yell what is wrong with you can you be
grateful for one thing in your life
and things get worse from there he
screams I hate you he runs out of the
room and he slams his bedroom door and
now my self-loathing session begins as I
say to myself what is wrong with me
I've messed up my kid forever
well if you're a parent you've probably
felt that pain
for me it comes with an extra layer of
Shame
I mean I'm a clinical psychologist and
my specialty is helping people become
better parents
this is true as well there is no such
thing as a perfect parent
mistakes and struggles they come with
the job but no one tells us what to do
next
do we just move on kind of just pretend
the whole thing never happened
or if I say something what are the words
well for years as a clinical
psychologist in private practice I saw
client after client struggle with this
question
and now as the creator of the parenting
content and Community platform good
inside I see millions of parents around
the globe struggle with this issue
all parents yell
no one knows what to do next
well I'm determined to fill this Gap
after all there's almost nothing within
our interpersonal relationships that can
have as much impact as repair whenever a
parent asks me what one parenting
strategy should I focus on I always say
the same thing get good at repair
so what is repair
is the act of going back to a moment of
disconnection taking responsibility for
your behavior and acknowledging the
impact it had on another
and I want to differentiate a repair
from an apology because one apology
often looks to shut a conversation down
hey I'm sorry I yelled can we move on
now
a good repair opens one up
and if you think about what it means to
get good at repair there's so much faked
in realism and hope and possibility
repair assumes there's been a rupture
so to repair you have to mess up or fall
short of someone else's expectations
which means the next time I snap at my
kid or my husband or my work colleague
instead of berating myself like I did
that night in the kitchen I try to
remind myself
I'm focusing on getting good at repair
Step One is rupture
check that off I crushed it
step two is repair
I can do this
I'm actually right on track
so let's get back to my example I'm in
the kitchen my son is in his room well
what will happen if I don't repair
that's really important to understand
and helps us make a decision about what
to do next
well here are the facts my son is alone
overwhelmed and in a state of distress
because let's face it his mom just
became scary mom
and now he has to figure out a way to
get back to feeling safe and secure
and if I don't go help him do that
through making a repair he has to rely
on one of the only coping mechanisms he
has at his own disposal
self-blame
self-blame sounds like this
something's wrong with me
I'm unlovable
I make bad things happen
Ronald Fairburn may have said it best
when he wrote that for kids it is better
to be a sinner in a world ruled by God
than to live in a world ruled by the
devil
in other words it's actually adaptive
for a child to internalize Badness and
fault because at least then they can
hold on to the idea that their parents
and the world around them is safe and
good
and while self-blame works for us in
childhood we all know it works against
us in adulthood
something's wrong with me I make bad
things happen I'm unlovable these are
the core fears of so many adults but
really we see here they are actually the
childhood stories we wrote when we were
left alone following distressing events
that went unrepaired
plus adults with self-blame are
vulnerable to depression anxiety deep
feelings of worthlessness none of which
we want for our kids
and we can do better and it doesn't mean
we have to be perfect when you repair
you go further than removing a child's
story of self-blame you get to add in
all the elements that we're missing in
the first place
safety connection coherence love
goodness
it says if you're saying to a child I
will not let this chapter of your life
end in self-blame
yes this chapter will still contain the
event of yelling but I can ensure this
chapter has a different ending
and therefore a different title and
theme and lesson learned
we know that memory is original events
combined with every other time you've
remembered that event
this is why therapy is helpful right
when you remember painful experiences
from your past within a safer and more
connected relationship
the event remains but your story of the
event it changes and then you change
with repair we effectively change the
past
so let's write a better story let's
learn how to repair
step one repair with yourself
that's right I mean you can't offer
Compassion or groundedness or
understanding to someone else before you
access those qualities within yourself
repair means separating your identity
Who You Are
from your behavior what you did
for me it means telling myself two
things are true I'm not proud of my
latest behavior and my latest Behavior
doesn't Define me
even as I struggle on the outside
I remain good inside
I can then start to see that I'm a good
parent identity who was having a hard
time behavior and no this doesn't let me
off the hook this is precisely what
leaves me on the hook for change because
now that I've replaced my spiral with
groundedness I can actually use my
energy toward thinking about what I want
to do differently the next time
oh and I can now use my energy to go
repair with my son
step two repair with your child
there's no exact formula I often think
about three elements name what happened
take responsibility State what you would
do differently the next time it could
come together like this
hey
I keep thinking about what happened the
other night in the kitchen
I'm sorry I yelled
I'm sure that felt scary
and it wasn't your fault
I'm working on staying calm even when
I'm frustrated
a 15 second intervention can have a
lifelong impact I've replaced my child's
story of self-blame with a story of
self-trust and safety and connection I
mean what a massive upgrade
and to give a little more clarity around
how to repair
I want to share a few examples of what I
call not repair which are things that
come more naturally to most of us
definitely me included
hey I'm sorry I yelled at you in the
kitchen but you know if you wouldn't
have complained about dinner it wouldn't
have happened
been there been there okay or
you know you really need to be grateful
for things in your life like a
home-cooked meal then you won't get
yelled at
not only do these interventions fail at
the goal of reconnection they also
insinuate that your child caused your
reaction which simply isn't true and
isn't a model of emotion regulation we
want to pass on to the next generation
so let's say we've all resisted the it
was your fault anyway not repairs and
have instead prioritized a repair that
allows us to reconnect what might the
impact be what might that look like in
adulthood
my adult child won't spiral and
self-blame when they make a mistake and
won't take on blame for someone else's
mistake
my adult child will know how to take
responsibility for their behavior
because you've modeled how to take
responsibility for yours
repairing with a child today sets the
stage for these critical adult
relationship patterns
plus it gets better now that I've
reconnected with my son
I can do something really impactful I
can teach him a skill he didn't have in
the first place which is how kids
actually change their behavior
so maybe the next day I say you know
you're not always going to like what I
make for dinner instead of saying that's
disgusting I wonder if you could say not
my favorite
now I'm teaching him how to regulate his
understandable disappointment and
communicate effectively and respectfully
with another person that never would
have happened if instead I had been
blaming him for my reaction
so here's the point where you might have
a lingering concern maybe you're
thinking
you know I have a feeling my kid's older
than your kid
I think it's too late
or
I've done a lot worse than you did in
the kitchen
maybe it's too late
well I mean this if you have only one
takeaway from this talk please let this
be it it is not too late it is never too
late
how do I know
well imagine right after this you get a
call from one of your parents
and if neither of your parents are alive
imagine finding and opening a letter you
hadn't seen until that moment
okay walk through this with me here's
the call
hey
I know this sounds out of the blue
but I've been thinking a lot about your
childhood
and I think there were a lot of moments
that felt really bad to you
and you were right to feel that way
those moments weren't your fault
they were times when I was struggling
and if I could have gone back I would
have stepped aside I would have calmed
myself down and then found you to help
you with whatever you were struggling
with
I'm sorry
and if you're ever willing to talk to me
about any of those moments I'll listen
I won't listen to have a rebuttal
I'll listen to understand
I love you
I don't know many adults who don't have
a fairly visceral reaction to that
exercise
I often hear
why am I crying
or listen that wouldn't change
everything
but it might change some things
well I definitely do not special in math
but here's something I know a certainty
if you have a child that child is
younger than you are
always true
the story of their life is shorter
and even more amenable to editing
so if that imagined exercise had an
impact on you
imagine the impact and actual repair
will have on your child
see I told you
it's never too late
thank you
[Applause]